Traductor: Paula Motter
Revisor: Florencia Bracamonte
La curiosidad:
¿bendición o maldición?
Para los antiguos griegos,
la paradójica naturaleza de esta cualidad
se encarnaba en la mítica
figura de Pandora.
Cuenta la leyenda que Pandora
fue la primera mujer mortal,
cuya intensa curiosidad desató una serie
de hechos que sacudieron al mundo.
Pandora nació por obra
de Hefesto, el dios del fuego,
quien convocó a otras divinidades para
que le confiriesen dotes extraordinarias.
Afrodita le dio la capacidad
de sentir emociones profundas,
Hermes le concedió
el don de la elocuencia,
Atenea la dotó del domino del arte
manual y la habilidad de ver los detalles,
y Hermes le dio el nombre.
Por último, Zeus
le concedió dos obsequios.
El primero fue el don de la curiosidad,
que definió su personalidad
y la lanzó, ansiosa, a explorar el mundo.
El segundo fue una pesada caja,
profusamente adornada
y firmemente cerrada.
Pero Zeus le advirtió que ningún
mortal debía ver su contenido.
Pandora no debía abrir la caja
bajo ninguna circunstancia.
En la Tierra, Pandora se enamoró
de Epimeteo, un talentoso titán
a quien Zeus había encargado
la tarea de diseñar el mundo natural.
Trabajó con su hermano Prometeo,
quien creó a los primeros humanos,
pero fue castigado eternamente
por haberles concedido el fuego.
Epimeteo echaba mucho
de menos a su hermano,
pero encontró en Pandora
la compañía de otra alma apasionada.
Pandora se sentía exultante
en su vida terrenal,
pero se distraía con facilidad
y era a veces impaciente,
dada su sed de conocimiento
y su deseo de cuestionar el entorno.
Con frecuencia, se preguntaba qué
contendría aquella caja tan bien cerrada.
¿Qué tesoro sería tan valioso
que no podía ser visto por ningún humano,
y por qué fue elegida
para custodiar el obsequio?
Sus manos apenas resistían
la tentación de abrirla.
A veces, creía oír voces
susurrantes en su interior
y que el contenido se agitaba
como si quisiera liberarse del encierro.
El enigma empezaba a enloquecerla.
Con el tiempo, Pandora se
obsesionaba cada vez más por la caja.
Era como si una fuerza incontrolable
la atrajera hacia el contenido,
que repetía su nombre
en un eco ensordecedor.
Cierto día, la tentación
se tornó irresistible.
A escondidas de Epimeteo,
fijó su mirada en la enigmática caja.
Tan solo espiaría en su interior,
y saciaría su curiosidad para siempre...
Pero ante el primer crujido de la tapa,
la caja se abrió violentamente.
Salieron monstruosas
criaturas y horribles sonidos
que envolvieron a Pandora en una nube
de humo, emitiendo chillidos y carcajadas.
Presa del terror,
Pandora agitó el aire con sus manos,
desesperada por regresarlas a su encierro,
pero las criaturas formaron
una nube de temerario aspecto.
Una sensación premonitoria embargó
a Pandora mientras las veía alejarse.
Zeus había usado la caja
para encerrar los sufrimientos
y todas las fuerzas del mal
que él mismo había creado
y, una vez liberadas, eran incontrolables.
Pandora estaba sumida en llanto,
cuando se percató de un sonido
que resonaba dentro de la caja.
No era el escalofriante
susurro de los demonios,
sino un suave tintineo
que parecía aliviar su angustia.
Cuando volvió a levantar la tapa
para mirar en el interior,
un cálido haz de luz salió
formando ondas en el aire.
Mientras veía los destellos alejarse
luego de haber liberado los males,
Pandora sintió que su dolor se calmaba.
Sabía que ya no podría revertir su error
pero, junto con los males,
Pandora también había liberado
la esperanza para combatirlos.
Actualmente, la caja de Pandora
representa las consecuencias extremas
de interferir con lo desconocido.
Pero la insaciable curiosidad
de Pandora también representa
la dualidad inherente al espíritu
inquisitivo del ser humano.
¿Estamos destinados a investigar
todo lo que desconocemos
e indagar en profundidad,
o conviene dejar que algunos
misterios queden sin resolver?